today on the Matt Walsh show many people
even conservatives are claiming that the
protests are mostly peaceful and have an
important message that we need to hear
now I think both of those claims are
delusional and also cowardly and I'll
explain why and then five headlines
including the retired police captain who
was gunned down by rioters in st. Louis
he's a black man he was killed not the
only black person to be killed in these
riots through their lives matter' seems
to the media they don't matter very much
because the media is not talking about
it but we're gonna talk about that today
plus our daily cancellation and much
more but we start here because there's
something in I feel really needs to be
needs to be said and I want to be very
clear about this let me be at least one
person to say point-blank that I do not
support these protests
I don't think they're mostly peaceful I
don't support anything about them I
don't support the peaceful elements I
don't support the violent elements I
don't support any of it
now given that these quote-unquote
protests and by the way just every time
you hear me say protests today in your
head
apply the air quotes because I can't say
quote-unquote protest every single time
that'll get old so given that these
protests have come packaged with rioting
and looting all across the country and
the nation has been in the grip of
anarchy and chaos and arson and murder
for a week because of it and given that
in fact these BLM / antifa protests are
almost always violent everywhere all the
time for years now you know it really
shouldn't be necessary for me to say
that I don't support them is it it
should be a necessary thing for anyone
to say especially as a conservative it
should be obvious and there should be
nothing bold or notable about saying
that except that what I've noticed is
even many conservatives conservative
commenters pundits just normal
conservative non media people many of
them have gone out of their way to say
that while they condemn the rioting and
the looting they realize that the
protest itself is mostly peaceful and
anyway they support the message of the
peaceful protest an important
message that we all need to hear it's
such an important message in fact just
as an example of what I'm talking about
I got into a back-and-forth with the
woman named Ariel Davidson yesterday
she's a staffer for I think Dan Crenshaw
and I have no beef with her or anything
okay but her position here is
representative of what so many people on
the right are saying and so I just want
to use this as an example so she tweeted
it's possible to support the protests
recognize injustice seek dialog and
condemn looting all at once
it's possible I saw that and I responded
no I don't think it's possible to
meaningfully condemn the looting while
supporting the protest the looting and
the rioting is inextricably linked with
the protest so that's why it's happening
in every major city where there is a
protest that's not a coincidence
and then her response was the rioters
are individuals abusing the protest
which is why they come out nearly
exclusively at night you're doing
express Eisley what the left is doing
collapsing the distinction in condemning
at all I think the rioting is abhorrent
I think the protests are important okay
and like I said my objective is not to
pick on miss Davis in here but I'm just
using us as an example as far as her
saying you're doing what the left is
doing condemning at all I don't know
what that means the left certainly is
not condemning at all they're doing the
exact opposite there they're supporting
and in justifying all of it
rationalizing all of it but in any case
the rest of that I you know I've seen a
lot of this from the left and right this
is another example of the right
accepting adopting promoting the talking
points of the left and this is something
that right-wingers are kind enough to do
generous enough to do even as left-wing
mobs are roving through our cities
killing people and committing mass arson
now very generous and very kind isn't it
people on the right we have a tendency
to do that in general to accept to
kindly and generously very tolerant ly
accept the talking points of the left
well we're doing it even now even as
there are left-wing mobs destroying our
cities we're allowing the
left to frame it to tell us how we
should view this the left says no I know
you well here's what the left is telling
us yeah you see all these roving mobs
killing people setting things on fire
stealing stuff but this is mostly
peaceful and and and that is how you're
supposed to see this and then so many
people on the right say oh well if you
say so
if you say so then that must be the case
so there are two points about these
protests that I want to make here even
the peaceful variety let me tell you why
I don't support them which is to say by
the way or isn't it that's to say I
don't support the message of the protest
it's not to say I don't support the
right to peacefully protest obviously I
support anybody's right to stand outside
waving a sign around and shouting
slogans as far as I'm concerned you can
do that any time you want anywhere you
want that's been my point for the last
three months even during the coronavirus
I think you have a right to go out and
protest it's it's in the the the First
Amendment the right to peacefully
assemble so I believe in that I don't
support your right to ransack a
Quickstop and set it ablaze and steal a
bunch of liquor that I don't support but
as for the signs and slogans short now
with that said the issue with these
protests is twofold and I'm gonna get to
both of those in just one second but
before we do I want to tell you about
LegalZoom you know putting together in a
state plan it's not something that a lot
of us especially if you're a little bit
younger but you're not thinking much
about it but it is it is something we
should think about and it's not
something you want to put off health and
safety is on the top of everybody's
minds right now no matter what happens
you want to make sure that your loved
ones are protected that's why Legal Zoom
continues to provide a reliable way for
everyone to set up right a real estate
plans without leaving your home they
make it easy they make it you know
something that anyone can handle it
starts with fighting the right answers
to your questions you know do you need a
last will and testament or a living
trust what about an advanced health care
directive
what's power of attorney these are all
the kind of basic questions that I know
that I have that's why I go to Legal
Zoom
you don't have to figure everything out
on your own legal zooms online resources
make it easy to get started and if you
need to speak to an attorney their
independent attorney network is there to
guide you and advise you Legal Zoom it's
not a law firm so you don't have to
worry about expensive billable hours
adding up they just make it very very
easy and that's why you could take care
of this you don't need to go walk it
into a lawyer's office as daunting as
expensive as that can be take an
important step for your family today go
to Legal Zoom calm to get started on a
last will living trusts and more and
make sure the enter code Walsh at
checkout for special savings that's
legalzoom.com code Walsh Legal Zoom
where life meets legal okay
so it's a couple things are first of all
I have to tell you this this argument
the following argument seems very weak
to me this argument where you say well
it was a peaceful protest except for the
entire city block set on fire dozens of
stores looted store owners beaten by
two-by-fours cops assaulted with bricks
and bystanders murdered in cold blood on
the sidewalk
except for that it was peaceful you know
that's essentially the argument that
even conservatives are making it's
delusional if a protest that includes
arson murder and looting you know if
that's peaceful then I don't know what
the word peaceful mean by definition it
would seem to me that is a not peaceful
protest if you asked me to define what a
not peaceful protest is I would say well
it's that I mean turn on the news that
right there that's what it is
if these protests qualifies peaceful
then then what does a protest have to do
to be not peaceful if mass anarchy in
the streets and turning places like
midtown Manhattan into war zones if that
isn't enough to earn the label of a non
peaceful protest then what the hell
would what do you need to see what do
you need to see before you will admit
that we have a situation on our hands
where this is a non peaceful protest it
do you need do you need do they need to
set off a nuke do they need to literally
just start nuking the entire city is
that what we need to see I think even
then even if they set off a nuclear bomb
in New York City you would still have
people said yeah they nuked the entire
city and killed you know ten million
people but it was mostly peaceful except
for that it was peaceful and that this
is not just one time okay this is not
one example the rioting isn't fringe it
isn't isolated it's been this way for
years for years it's been this way has
everybody forgotten BLM came along and
there was rioting in Ferguson and
Baltimore Sousa come on that's another
reason why we can't blame this all in on
an Tifa that's actually a safe thing to
do
so the consent for conservatives out
there saying the violence is all
happening from antiva that these are all
white and Tifa people from the suburbs
right causing all the Von's yes they are
violence and they're involved in this
yes that's true
but if you're trying to make this all
about anti feh then you're doing that
because it's safe and you know what
you're doing because I don't know
everyone everyone else has forgotten but
I seem to remember a time when an Tifa
didn't exist and we had BLM protests
that where there was rioting and looting
and all of this stuff I mean I seem to
remember a BLM protest in Dallas where
five police officers were executed has
everybody forgotten that and then an
Tifa is born and their insult their
assaulting people and rioting all over
the country as well so you've got BLM
they come along there's rioting Ferguson
Baltimore other cities as well and then
we've got five cops being shot to death
in Dallas and Tifa comes more rioting
now we join the two together and the
country descends into full-blown anarchy
and yet people are still looking at this
and going yeah you know peaceful pest
looks beautiful to me I don't know as it
me what I think peace and harmony I
think that no these these aren't
peaceful protests these are not peaceful
protests that happened to coincidentally
accidentally by happenstance turned
violent always everywhere all the time
for years on end no these are violent
demonstrations that happen to also
include some peaceful people and those
peaceful protesters many of them the
actual peaceful ones they're not very
that they're not really that peaceful
because they support the violence they
are happy to march alongside it here's a
quick clip making this point here's a me
Horowitz interviewing some of the
so-called peaceful protesters and here's
what they had to say about all the
violence the media narrative has been
that the protesters and the violence are
distinct but the vast majority of
protesters that I spoke to went out of
their way to justify in a non socially
distance way the anarchic orgy of
violence Target Walmart Georgia saying
hey man you're not giving it to us so
we're gonna take it Marcus oh that's all
built up that's all slavery money it's
America so we take it back we burn it
down we can that for size you won't give
it up okay you a having aroma
but it's not just large corporations
that have been attacked many small
businesses that have already been
decimated by the coronavirus have been
utterly destroyed do we have to burn it
down to rebuild it without racism yes
and this also is not isolated the excuse
making the rationalizing justifying of
violence in fact to here basically the
same damn thing from the media from CNN
I played you the clip yesterday of a CNN
reporter making excuses making basically
the same argument Cuomo fredo on CNN
last night said that you know what where
is it written that protests have to be
polite and peaceful in fact let's play
that clip for let let's play Chris Cuomo
last night it is a sad day when we need
curfews in our cities America's major
cities are filled with people demanding
this country become more fair more just
and ironically more United now too many
see the protests as the problem no the
problem is what forced your fellow
citizens to take to the streets
persistent and poisonous inequities and
injustice and please show me where it
says that protests are supposed to be
polite and peaceful who says they have
to be peaceful well I don't know the law
the law says that it's supposed to be
peaceful the law says you don't have the
right to go out and be violent you know
that little old thing called the law I
know it's not being enforced right now
but it does exist so again the peaceful
version of this protest by and large
supports the non peaceful part of it
they are two sides of the same coin this
idea that the vast majority of
protesters are peaceful is so Orwellian
in its contradiction of the facts so so
hallucinatory that it really it makes me
feel like I'm surrounded by lunatics I
feel that way all the time I feel
especially now in the last few days with
the things people are saying about what
we are all witnessing maybe I'm
hallucinating I mean is it a guess
that's
possible that I'd like take some LSD and
I don't know maybe I'm hallucinating and
and there's not actually cities on fire
I may be I'm gonna crazy one no cities
are being set on fire across the country
and everyone is just strolling by
whistling to themselves going oh my oh
my look at all those peaceful
demonstrations
what are you maniacs talking about what
peaceful demonstration here's the thing
if the vast majority of protesters are
peaceful are truly peaceful as is
claimed there isn't going to be arson
and looting and murder how do I know
that well because the vast majority of
pro-life protesters are peaceful and I
have been to a lot of peaceful prolife
protests and there was none of this none
not a single fire set not a single
person hit with a brick amazing how that
works when you've actually got a vast
majority of peaceful people and they get
together of her protest guess what
happens they March and they sing and
they pray and they go home the vast
majority of Second Amendment advocates
are peaceful and therefore every pro-gun
rally is peaceful the vast majority of
tea partiers were peaceful and therefore
every single Tea Party rally was
peaceful you see how this works well it
doesn't work the way for these
protesters does it what does that tell
you about them second point here I say I
don't support the protest but what about
the truly peaceful ones I mean even if
the protests themselves are
fundamentally not peaceful which which
I'm saying they are fundamentally not
peaceful it's true that some of the
people there aren't burning stuff or
stealing stuff right what about them do
I support them no I don't I don't
support them either my heart is not
cheered and gladdened when I see the
peaceful ones walking and marching no
it's not I don't support them
and and that's in that this is where it
troubles me when conservatives say that
the peaceful protesters have an
important message really do they what is
their message if you think their message
is just that cops shouldn't be brutal
and shouldn't commit with brutality
that's not their message
you might try actually listening to what
they're saying read the damn signs okay
listen to the arguments they're making
for what they're worth
let them speak for themselves that is
not their point in fact BLM is very open
about what it believes go to their
website they have their own website you
can go and look see their list of
demands I did just that it's right there
on the homepage let me read a little bit
this is black lives matter okay and
here's what black lives matter website
says it says George Floyd's violent
death was a breaking point an
all-too-familiar reminder that for black
people law enforcement doesn't protect
or serve serve are or save our lives
they often threaten and take them right
now Minneapolis and cities across the
country are on fire and our people are
hurting the violence against black
bodies felt in the ongoing mass
disobedience all while we grapple with a
pandemic that is disproportionately
affecting infecting and killing us we
call for an end to the systemic racism
that allows this culture of corruption
to go unchecked and our lives to be
taken we call for a national defunding
of police we demand investment in our
communities and the resources to ensure
black people not only survive but thrive
if you're with us add your name to the
petition right now currently we're if we
are fighting two deadly viruses kovat 19
is threatening our health white
supremacy is threatening our existence
and both are killing us every single day
okay so defund the police America is
systemically racist cops don't protect
or save black people white supremacy is
a deadly virus black people are killed
every day by white supremacist these are
the views of BLM these are BLM protests
that America is a racist country that
racist cops are out hunting black people
that we
fundamentally white-supremacist that
there are white supremacists killing
black people in this country every
single day which by the means by the way
means we should have at least what 365
black victims of white supremacist
violence every year that's what we
should see what we we don't see anything
close to that but that's the claim
anyway and that's just the beginning we
haven't even gotten to their views on
capitalism and everything else and we've
got conservatives saying this is
important this is an important message
you support this message really don't
try to backtrack now and say I just
support their right to vote yes we all
support everybody supports the right for
people to March and hold signs well at
least now everybody supports I mean for
the last three months a lot of people
didn't support it but anyway I support
it okay I've always supported it that's
not what we're talking about when you
Syst when you say I support the protest
you are not saying I support the right
to protest you are saying you support
the message which is why a pro-abortion
person would never say I support the
March for Life okay and if there was a
shout your abortion protest okay in
Portland somewhere I'm not gonna say I
support the shout your abortion protest
in Portland everybody would know what I
mean by that right when you say that
what you're saying is you support the
message and so all these conservatives
saying I support the message I support
all right I support the protest I said
you're saying you support the message of
black lives matter you support the
message that America is fundamentally
and systemically racist that cops are
white supremacist out hunting for black
people
good god I mean I thought we believed
that America is not fundamentally racist
and that though some cops are bad apples
the police are not by and large a bunch
of racist thugs out looking for black
men to murder we better think that
because that's the reality this stuff
you're getting from black lives matter
is delusional insanity it is not even
close to true
they have no
for it these are bald assertions that
are not supported by any of the facts
none of them don't just go along with it
because they're upset and emotional I've
actually had people tell me that they've
told me they've told me well you know
this might not be true but but people's
emotions are true and and they feel this
way I don't care how you feel the
reality is the reality if you feel like
a certain thing as a reality and it's
not the reality then the best thing I
can do for you is tell you that's not
the reality so if there's anyone out
there that feels like cops are you know
involved in a racist conspiracy to
execute black people if you feel that
way well the best thing I can do is is
is tell you the good news that that's
not true at all and there is no evidence
up for it at all we just go along within
it so how they feel that way so wait and
then what happens you got police
stations burned to the ground here's the
thing if it were true that the police
that that essentially policing is a is a
white supremacist conspiracy which is
what BLM believes if that was true then
actually they'd be justified in burning
not believe they should be burning down
more police stations I mean burning down
the police station of Minneapolis would
be like the only justified thing they've
done but it's not true that's why it's
so damned important to say it's not true
if we are buying into these lines and
these lies we might as well grab a brick
and start smashing windows - because we
are the left we have joined them we have
given up on the truth we have let them
completely tell the story of our society
right the narrative and we've done it
for fear that otherwise they'll call us
racist I mean we've given up on society
because we're afraid of people calling
us names
ABB's
pathetic disgusted by it now let's move
on to headlines number one it is
interesting that's a black lives matter
movement should be so deadly for black
lives but that's where we are now David
Dorn was a 77 year old black man and st.
Louis retired police captain good man by
all accounts good citizen and we know
that about him by the way this is not
just like some anytime someone dies we
always hear what a great person they
were whether they were or not in this
case you know we know that this was a
good man because he he not only did he
serve in a distinguished capacity for so
many years as a police captain he showed
up in downtown and st. Louis over the
weekend despite being a 77 year old man
you know to try to stop looters from
breaking into a pawn shop this was a man
who put his life on the line sacrificed
his life they think about that you I'm
not sure how long he served in the in
the in the police force presumably for
decades gave so much of his life to that
retires and if I'm him I'm thinking I'm
retired I'm out of here I'm not due I'm
not going anywhere near this crap okay
that's what I'm thinking as a selfish
person but him as a selfless person
thinks I'm gonna jump right back into
this because I'm not gonna let this
happen to my city he goes out and and
he's shot by one of the looters
apparently coming out with a TV shoot
him in the gut he bleeds to death on the
sidewalk there's video out there of it
it's in it's heart-wrenching it shows
him lying there bleeding dying someone
else not the shooter someone else is
filming it had had already called the
police apparently was waiting for the
cops to show up and you can hear this
man shouting at the looters who murdered
Dorn saying basically you did this all
for a TV you took a man's life for a TV
it's raw you know it's very raw it's
very powerful very hard to watch I'm not
gonna play it because it's graphic and
bloody as well but if you want to see
the video you can you could find it Dorn
was not the only plort person or black
person killed in the riots
David Underwood security guard black man
was murdered on Friday another victim 22
year old Italia Marie Kelly a biracial
woman shot by a protester here is Italia
sister on Facebook live shortly after
her sister was shot and killed and here
she is reacting as any sister would so I
ask again when are we just going to
speak plainly about this evil I don't
want to hear about the peacefulness of
it the legitimacy of the message the
pain of the rioters so tired of hearing
that what about her pain rub that woman
what other pain of David Dorn's wife
whose husband led a distinguished heroic
life was a good man and died lying on a
sidewalk streamed live on Facebook what
about him that he deserved that kind of
death does his life matter all the the
Democrats Joe Biden apparently is gonna
go to George Floyd's funeral
you're gonna go to David Dorn Sphero
funeral what about him all these
Democrats are gonna show up to his
funeral you're gonna say anything about
him you can apologize to his wife for
fomenting the chaos that killed him
you're gonna do that no you're not
because you're a bunch of cowardly
scumbag garbage people
number two dozens of speaking of garbage
people dozens of public health experts
again air quotes public health experts
have signed a letter supporting the
protests they said quote white supremacy
is a lethal public health issue that
predates and contributes to kovat 19 I
served what you got to laugh because you
know I have done enough screaming
already today I'm having an aneurysm I
mean where to even begin now the letter
goes on and there's there's more and
it's all just totally absurd where to
eat them again let's start with white
supremacy contributes to kovin 19th
these are public health experts
supposedly what okay we beget we
actually begin with white supremacy as a
lethal public health issue is it how so
I ask again how many people have
actually been killed by white
supremacists in like I don't know the
last 30 years tell me now yes if you're
gonna chalk every single police shooting
up to white supremacy which is what BLM
does then sure you've got you could say
that there have been even then it
wouldn't be nearly as many as they lead
you to believe but then you'd have
hundreds of deaths but of course that is
delusional and insane once again
contributes to Cova 19 how does that
work and aside from all of that these
are the same people who told us that if
you get together in large groups many
people will die because of it grandma is
gonna die people get you gonna be
spreading the virus to people these are
the same people told us that and now
they've just discarded all of that said
like it never happened
meanwhile if you know if you believe
black lives matter and you also believe
that large gatherings are gonna kill a
lot of people
what are you doing encouraging large
crowds many of them black to come
together aren't by your own thinking
aren't you encouraging them to infect
themselves and die
if you really believe what these public
health experts have been saying for the
last three months and you also believe
the black lives matter then what you
would be saying is stay the hell home
don't gather number three here's some
some news from The Daily Star it's it
says an asteroid about the size of the
Empire State Building is rocketing
towards Earth at 11,000 miles an hour I
always wonder why these kinds of stories
are always reported by at these
publications like Daily Star or you know
I mean it just seems like dishes should
be bigger news but really this is
terrible news when you think about it
asteroid the size of the Empire State
Building rocketing towards Earth
very tragic it's the last thing we need
right now an asteroid that size isn't
nearly big enough to do the job awful
just our luck right when you think we're
off the hook finally it's coming no
that's uh that's not gonna do it not
good enough number four here's some real
good news finally Grindr the gay dating
app has announced that in a show of
solidarity with the black lives matter
movement it will remove the racial and
ethnic filters from their site so it
means I guess you can't search for a
particular race or ethnicity if you're
on Grindr you know looking for a date
and with this move with this decision by
Grindr racial harmony has fallen upon
the land and all is right in the world
again and there is peace and there is
understanding Grindr has saved us all
inspiring stuff number five here's
something that's also supposed to be
inspiring I guess there was a clip like
this that I played yesterday this one's
even worse or even better depending on
if we're talking about from a comedic
perspective then it's even better but
anyway take a take a look at this about
racism and blackness or violence
I will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible and to everything
in my powers I speak my community I will
love my black neighbors the same as my
white ones I actually died of
second-hand embarrassment watching that
I died right here you didn't see it
because it was off air and then God sent
me back into this world as a punishment
for my sins because let's be honest
right now this world is sort of
indistinguishable from hell anyway so
here I am again and that video is just I
I really think that that we should
replace the definition of cringe in the
Vics dictionary with the URL of that
video this is literally the definition
of cringe it's also the definition of
creepy and cultish what we're seeing
here are people without religion without
purpose without direction without an
avenue or a channel for repentance
adopting the religion of left-wing
racialism and using white guilt as their
outlet for repentance that's that's what
this is these these are creepy cultish
weirdos so when you look at these
protests you know a lot of the peaceful
ones are creepy cultish weirdos and then
you've got the the other ones that are
burning down buildings it's almost like
the ones burning down buildings are more
normal somehow somehow the ones burning
buildings manage to be a little bit less
creepy than what you just saw there this
is this is not it this is just not it
folks and it's it's it's not gonna solve
anything and I tell you also if you're a
white person literally on your knees
with your hands up repeating whatever
the black lives matter you know person
is telling you it's if
if you think that's gonna save you from
accusations of being part of the white
supremacist conspiracy or white
privilege it won't if you think it's
gonna save you from charges of bigotry
it won't and if you think that when the
rioting mob comes to your neighborhood
it's gonna save your house from getting
burned down it won't just say you know
you'll lose your house like anybody else
would
but you've also lost your dignity ahead
of time so you're left without a house
or dignity that's that's that's the
situation you're gonna be in finally
here's a bonus video I wanted to play
very quickly I just I have to play it no
setup is really needed here it is I feel
like this needs to be said and I really
wish that more people would connect
these two dots but literally all
sentient beings on this planet deserve a
life free from fear free from abuse free
from unjust prosecution no one whether
it's a human being especially ones
differently colored skin than yours and
animals who are different creatures than
yours this is their time to die they
don't deserve
so stop killing black people and stop
killing animals and it's important each
one of them is so individually important
I really hope that people can start
distracted too you know I could be wrong
could be wrong but something tells me
this comparison between black lives
matter and animals isn't going to
necessarily resonate like that woman
thinks it will well see though I know
that that I don't know who that is is
some some vegan Instagram person I don't
know but she had she had to come up with
this whole speech and say to herself
this is gonna do yeah this is the thing
I said people are gonna love this yeah I
don't think it's gonna work out for her
finally let's go to our daily
cancelation and today we are
specifically canceling this guy Carl T
Bergstrom he's a professor at University
of Washington but we're also canceling
him for an argument that that that he
made that many people have made so
actually we're canceling everyone who's
made this argument Carl T Bergstrom is
just our example that we're using here's
what he said as protesters are being
beaten and gassed in the streets just a
reminder that a couple of weeks ago this
was tolerated inside a State Capitol
without a blast to pepper spray a raised
baton the use of tear gas or any damn
thing oh and these guys had
semiautomatic weapons and as a picture
of a lockdown protester seeming to
scream at police officers of course this
picture is misleading he was not
screaming at police officers he was
actually screaming at people behind the
cops but that part is cut out and then
in and then this that particular picture
went viral courtesy of the left lying
about it and saying that he was getting
in the face of the officer screaming at
him he wasn't in fact if you look at the
picture you can see clearly he is not
looking at that police officer he's
looking behind the police officer but in
any case this is the argument the
argument is that whites occur white
conservatives were able to protest with
guns and nobody was gassed or shot yet
these protesters are in the street right
now and they're getting tear gassed and
shot with rubber bullets and everything
else isn't that racism isn't that bias
well no because let me remind professor
Bergstrom that those protesters despite
having weapons didn't hurt anybody
didn't burn anything didn't steal
anything
didn't kill anyone didn't throw any
bricks didn't bash anyone over the head
with a 2x4 didn't set any cars on fire
whereas the BLM protesters have done all
of those things relentlessly across the
country for an entire week and actually
four years so do you understand the
difference professor I mean you're the
professor here okay I didn't even go to
college so I'm the idiot you're the
genius even despite that despite my lack
of a college education I can see the
difference you've got one group burning
stuff and stealing stuff and hurting
people and killing people then you've
got another group doing none of that and
so the former group gets a harsher
response let that make any sense to you
professor can you kind of understand why
there might be I mean when you've got
people holding scary guns and yelling
but not actually hurting a single fly
and you've got other people over here
some of them hurting some of them
actually holding guns and shooting
people with them and then others holding
bricks and using them to throw at people
and others you know holding torches and
setting some of the understand why that
other group over there with all the
violence that you see is I don't know
how to also explain it to you professor
I mean the whole idea anyway that that
police are being too harsh in their
response I keep using the word
delusional that's like Maya that's the
keyword of today but that's it's again
delusional police in many cities did
absolutely nothing for a week and it's
not their fault I think they were they
were told to stand down they were in
many cities they were hands tied behind
the back but in many cities these
rioters were given a week to essentially
destroy and steal and assault at will
with no repercussions and in seven eight
days later the cops finally show up and
start enforcing and you're complaining
that it's too harsh what do you want
professor Bergstrom do you think that
they should be allowed to just riot for
the next year how long mean let me just
add maybe just just let us know how long
do you think
rioters should be allowed to destroy
stuff before the cops respond apparently
a week isn't long enough so with two
weeks do it three weeks what are you
looking for the problem
from the police response isn't that it's
too harsh it's that it's not merely
harsh enough not even close to harsh
enough the very first person who threw a
brick in the very first city in
Minneapolis the first person who threw
one brick in Minneapolis should have
been immediately tackled by police and
arrested and hauled away right away
Minneapolis should have had buses out
there handcuffing people chaining them
up and marching them into the buses if
they were being violent there should be
zero tolerance for violence of this kind
or of any kind and you know you know
something
that's what would happen to me so all
this stuff about white supremacy I tell
you right now if I grab a brick and I go
into town and I throw it at a person at
a building at a car I'm gonna be
arrested I guarantee it there is zero
chance that I'm not arrested and if
there's a cop nearby watching me do it
I'll probably be arrested in it in a
pretty in a pretty harsh painful manner
like tackled to the street head bat
bashes against the concrete like that's
what's going to happen if I do it
and yet we've got I mean hundreds of
people across the country who've been
able to do this with no repercussions
and you're saying that there's bias
against them yeah there is bias here
professor but it's bias in their favor
because again they are being allowed to
do stuff that I could never do despite
being a white person tell you right now
I set a building on fire my ass is going
to jail but if you're part of one of
these protests apparently and you set
something on fire
there's very good chance you'll get to
walk away not just walk away but you can
walk away with a handful of stolen
merchandise not just that but you can be
on camera you can have your face on
camera and walk away with stolen
merchandise and it'll be no arrests yeah
oh yeah but there's bias against them
sure okay thanks professor brilliant
stuff is always from our illustrious
professors that are at our institutions
of higher education and we will leave it
there for today thanks for watching
everybody thank you for listening a
great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]